[Music]
so if you'd like to see more of what i
show you today and in more detail and
you know with me guiding you through the
process you can definitely find that in
my book bootstrapping microservices
before we get into the theory i'm just
going to give you a little bit of a demo
a little bit of a taster of where we're
going to get to at the end of this
so the end result of this is we want to
be able to kind of
update our infrastructure through code
we want to do that basically by pushing
code to our hosted code repository
having our continuous delivery pipeline
automatically kick in and do the work
for us and i'm just going to show you
what that looks like so i've prepared
some example code for today's
demonstration
you can find it on bitbucket
bootstrapping microservices bitbucket is
a little bit like github it's a place
where you can
host your code repositories i've got two
example code repositories here example
one and example two originally i was
going to go through both of these code
examples but we're probably not going to
have time in this live stream so today
we're just going to be looking at
example one which is an example of using
terraform to build a kubernetes cluster
on microsoft azure and then example two
is an example of how to build and deploy
a microservice to that kubernetes
cluster
so we're mostly just going to be looking
at example one today i'm just going to
drill down to that so this is a code
repository
you can see here a bunch of example code
anything ending in a tf file is a
terraform code file
we're going to be looking at the code in
there a little bit later
and i'm going to be explaining you know
how it fits together and what it means
for the moment i just want to show you
the end product which is the continuous
delivery pipeline in action if i click
on the pipelines tab here
you can see all the continuous delivery
pipelines that have been invoked for
this code repository obviously there's
been quite a few because i've been
practicing for this demo now this code
repo it's just like super simple it's
it's not a complicated infrastructure
but it's good for learning it's and it's
good for practicing and it's good for
demonstrations like this
so at the start of this uh back on the
original page
on the first invocation of this
continuous delivery pipeline that was
where the original kubernetes cluster
was created
so
what i have now here is an existing
kubernetes cluster and what i want to do
is i want to update it through code i've
already got a local copy of the code
which i've opened in visual studio code
here and this file is kubernetes
cluster.tf
oh by the way you know if you do want to
follow on you probably won't be able to
keep up with me live but you can you can
get this code repository later you can
clone this
or you can just download this directly
from here
and you can follow along
let's just go back into that pipelines
tab
i have to i have to be in the pipelines
tab just to show you what it's going to
do
so back to the code um this is the
configuration of my kubernetes cluster
i've got it set up with a node pool that
just has one virtual machine so this is
a kubernetes cluster that's powered by
one virtual machine not a very big
cluster we want to make this a little
bit more powerful we can change the node
count to two
i'm just going to save that
now i'll flip back to my terminal here
i'm actually running this on windows 10
today
but all the commands i'm going to show
you uh will work on linux and mac os
i've actually got git bash installed and
that comes with a whole bunch of linux
commands that you can use under windows
terminal so it's it's a really nice
setup and it's really uh it's really it
works across platform so you can see
here i've done an ls i've you can see
all the all the terraform files that
i've got
the one that i just changed is this
kubernetes cluster.tf now what i'm going
to do
i'm using git for version control
i'm just going to see what i've changed
i've changed one thing
like a good developer on any team i'm
going to diff my change just to make
sure that i'm not breaking anything so
you can see here that i've changed the
node count from one to two
i'm going to commit this change
put a nice commit comment
and now i'm going to push this to my
hosted code repository
now what you'll see now is this is going
to initiate
a pipeline so you can see we've got a
pipeline pending here and it's got my
commit comment scaling up the cluster to
two nodes now it's in progress
we can drill down into this and see what
it's doing you can see here it's running
a shell script called deploy.sh this is
something that's important i'm going to
show you this shell script a bit later
you can see here in the output of the
shell script that it's running terraform
and indeed it's actually now talking to
azure so you can see down here at the
bottom of the output it's talking to
azure it's making changes to my live
kubernetes cluster and it's updating the
cluster for me by the time this finishes
we're not gonna wait for it to finish
we're just gonna you know get on with
some theory and then then the full
demonstration this is just really a
taster to show you what infrastructure
is code is all about it's you make a
change to your code you push the change
and it automatically updates your
infrastructure for you so i'm just going
to leave that running so that was just a
taste of where we're headed today and
where we're going to get to by the end
of this we're going to be looking at
obviously the theme of this talk is
infrastructure as code we're going to
understand what it is
why you would want to use it and how to
use it we'll be using terraform as the
tool and the configuration language to
implement infrastructure as code and
i'll be giving you a live demonstration
of how we can run terraform locally to
create infrastructure in the cloud
and then how we wire that into our
continuous delivery pipeline to then put
it on automatic before diving into
infrastructure as code let's briefly
take a step back and understand what i
mean when i say infrastructure
infrastructure is simply the platform on
which we run our application for this
particular example
the application is one that i built
using microservices because you know
that's what i do that's what i wrote my
book about it doesn't have to be this
way of course you know this is just one
particular example you can see in the
diagram that we have a bunch of
microservices running on a kubernetes
cluster which is hosted in the cloud
you can see off to the left that a user
is interacting with our application
through a front end in a web browser
this talk it's not about you know
front-end stuff at all you could replace
that web browser there with it with a
mobile application it doesn't really
matter how the front end is delivered
what i'm talking about today is back end
it's completely server side nothing to
do with the front end but typically you
know the application that you put on
your infrastructure is going to be
accessible through a web browser or
through a mobile app or maybe through a
native desktop application even the
infrastructure in this example is
running on a kubernetes cluster and
that's the computing platform that our
application is running on so kubernetes
is an orchestration platform that allows
you to run containers
and i use it for my projects to run
micro services if you want to build an
application like this the first question
you need to ask is how are you going to
build the infrastructure how are we
going to build this kubernetes cluster
now we could build the infrastructure
manually and what i mean is that we
could go into the web portal for our
favorite cloud vendor and we could
create a kubernetes cluster using the
gui or
we could also build it using the command
line tools from our our cloud vendor
that's a really great way of doing it as
well and in fact if you want to if you
want to try doing this manually using
command line tools i have a blog post
for that if you go to my blog actually
i've already got this open
my blog is the datawrangler
if you scroll down a bit you can see
here the quick guide to creating a
kubernetes cluster if you drill through
that it will show you the quickest
sequence of steps to manually create a
kubernetes cluster on microsoft azure
using the command line getting a little
bit sidetracked we'll get back to the
slides it's perfectly okay to start a
new application by manually creating
your infrastructure building
infrastructure manually you know it's a
good way to learn
it's a good way to practice your skills
it might also be all that you need like
if you're building a small application
which has a small infrastructure that
that isn't going to change much in the
future
then it's completely okay for you to do
that manually you know if you are
building that small application and and
you don't see it as changing
you don't really need to automate your
deployments most infrastructures aren't
going to be like that of course in the
modern world with modern applications
and there's a bunch of problems with
manual deployment now as you might
imagine the applications we're building
these days are growing ever more complex
and as a result the deployment is
getting more and more complicated as
well
and the more complicated you make the
deployment the more potential there is
for human error the risk of error
means that the manual process isn't very
repeatable it's also very labor
intensive so
if you want if you need to do multiple
deployments and you have an actual
person going through all the steps all
the time it's going to be pretty time
consuming not to mention boring and if
it's boring the person likely won't be
paying as much attention as they should
and that further increases the risk of
mistakes ultimately manual deployment it
just isn't very scalable as your
infrastructure grows bigger and more
complicated manual deployment is just
going to work
less well for you of course the cure for
manual deployment
is of course to automate it
we'd like to make our deployments
reliable we can only do that by taking
the human out of the equation automation
also makes our deployments more
efficient and why would we want to pay a
human to spend hours doing something
that a machine can do in minutes
automation also makes the process
repeatable
and that means we can make multiple
copies of our infrastructure if we need
to that can be useful for performance
and fault tolerance and being able to
make new copies of our infrastructure on
demand is really useful for safely
releasing new updates to our customers
it means that we can employ a technical
blue-green deployment that utilizes two
copies of our infrastructure and also
useful
for us to be able to make multiple
environments so often on a software
development team we find it useful to be
able to create multiple multiple
instances of our infrastructure
and for it for example we'd like to have
an instance for development a separate
instance for testing and a completely
separate instance for our customers so
that they can you know use only the
tested version of the of the application
having automated deployment means that
um
as a last resort
we you know if we have infrastructure
that's not working so badly that you
know we can't fix it
we can simply nuke it and run our
scripts again to recreate it now that is
completely a last resort option
but it's something that um
automated deployment allows
and it's quite amazing really in the end
we need automated deployment for
scalability the amount of time it takes
a human to build the infrastructure it's
no longer and it should no longer be a
constraint for application design the
software industry has moved well beyond
that now we can automate our deployments
and that means we can deploy whenever
and wherever we like and as often as we
like without having to wait for a human
to put in the hours that would have been
required before we automated it so that
brings us to infrastructure as code and
to make a long story short
infrastructure as code it's simply the
technique where we manage infrastructure
uh
creation and updating and management
through code instead of creating that
infrastructure manually in a moment i'm
going to explain a little bit deeper
about infrastructure as code but for the
moment let's just take a look at this
diagram and we'll understand what i'm
going to demonstrate today you can see
the developer on the left here is using
terraform locally on their development
workstation
they're invoking the terraform tool to
run their infrastructure code
and that code is reaching out to the
cloud
to create and update their cloud-based
infrastructure in the demonstration
today i'm going to be showing how to use
terraform to create a kubernetes cluster
on azure and the process in this diagram
actually it's it shows you the way that
i prototype real infrastructure i write
and test code on my local computer
and that code
is then making changes to the
infrastructure in the cloud this diagram
shows where we'd like to end up with
with infrastructure as code you can see
the developer here on the left is
writing and testing his code locally
and
and they're committing code to their
local git repository
when they push code their hosted
repository is automatically triggering
the continuous delivery pipeline in this
example we're using terraform inside the
pipeline
it's running the code and it's creating
or updating the infrastructure in the
cloud
you know terraform is not the only tool
you could use here you could build your
own tools there's other tools you could
use this diagram shows a simplified
pipeline there's no checks or balances
in it you can't see any automated tests
here typically in a real pipeline you'd
have those stages those things and you'd
have multiple stages for possibly for
manual approvals and you know whatever
other testing um you know automated
compliance testing automated security
testing whatever other testing you want
to have in your pipeline to be sure that
safe code is getting rolled out to
production
so i've really simplified this for
today's demonstration
it doesn't include any of that um and
it's a lot it's a lot simpler than it
could be this pipeline makes for a
complete automated flow of
infrastructure changes from the
developer all the way through into
production and hopefully you can see
here you know why it's called
infrastructure as code it's the act of
changing code that triggers the pipeline
that is what makes changes to our
infrastructure once we have a pipeline
like this in place
we're now updating our infrastructure
through code changes so i'm just going
to get into a little bit more detail now
about infrastructure as code
we'll dive a bit deeper
so
infrastructure is code it's where we
manage our infrastructure through code
not only is our code the source of truth
about our application but it can become
now the source of truth about our
infrastructure and rather than being a
like a manual or or physical task the
act of creating infrastructure
has been converted to a coding task so
anything that's useful for coding
suddenly becomes useful for building
infrastructure that's important because
we've already amassed a large toolkit of
techniques for coding that we can now
apply to creating infrastructure
infrastructure as code usually means
that the management of our
infrastructure is automated and this is
a huge win for any modern business that
is trying to scale up because what we
want to do we want to
we want to grow our application to
support our expanding customer base and
we can't scale to any large extent
without automation infrastructure as
code then it provides
you know part of the basis um
that basically pays paves the way for
massive scalability why should we use
infrastructure as code
it's all about the automation you know
we're automating
uh the creation and maintenance of our
infrastructure and that has many
positive benefits
automation can really empower a small
team it's what allows us to achieve big
scalability with only a small workforce
it reduces the amount of manual work we
must do and this in turn frees up time
for us to work on the features that are
important to our customers it reduces
the risk of human error again this frees
up time because errors usually involve
quite a bit of time to correct the fact
is that automation makes deployments
cheaper and this is what makes small
deployments more cost effective and
actually this is one of the reasons why
microservices have exploded in
popularity recently
because they have become cost effective
to build and run so all this serves
basically to reduce the the risk that
any one deployment will fail and uh
infrastructure is code you know it's
making our updates more reliable the
process is faster and more repeatable
and the knock-on effect is that
we can safely increase the frequency of
our deployments
and thus we get more features more
quickly into the hands of customers
so we're increasing the pace at which we
roll out features that's of course the
reason why we're doing any of this we
are delivering application features to
our customers and anything that
streamlines that makes it safer makes it
faster that's going to give our business
a competitive advantage because our
infrastructure code it's the source of
truth about our application the code is
acting like a kind of a documentation
it documents the way our application or
our infrastructure is supposed to work
and it not only describes it
but also running the code is what brings
our infrastructure up to date so we know
that our documentation or this this
document
infrastructure code as documentation is
always going to be up to date because it
reflects what we have in production
another big reason to use infrastructure
as code is because it makes a coding
activity out of infrastructure
management because it becomes a coding
task you know we apply all the tools
that we normally use while coding things
like automated testing
we can use that time and time again to
automatically validate that our code is
working correctly we can use version
control to manage versioning of our
infrastructure as developers we often
take version control for granted
but it's amazing really it allows for a
kind of time travel like we can go back
into the past using version control
and we can reconstitute our
infrastructure as it was in the past
that's really useful if you want to
reproduce a bug or a feature or
something like that from the past you
can also use version control to roll
back changes um maybe maybe broken
changes roll back to a working version
we can use branches and labels to manage
different versions of our infrastructure
and one of my favorite things actually
is to use
a test branch that deploys to the the
test infrastructure a dev branch that
deploys to the dev infrastructure and a
prod branch that deploys to the
production infrastructure so we can
manage multiple instances of our
infrastructure using version control and
of course infrastructure is code it's a
it's a key enabler for continuous
delivery and that is what allows us to
automate the deployment of our
infrastructure so the question now is
how do we make use of it as with
anything in our industry there's so many
different ways we could do this there's
many different tools we could use and of
course today i'm focusing on terraform
which is one tool we can use for
infrastructure as code
we'd like to have our infrastructure
defined in code so that we can put it on
automatic in a continuous delivery
pipeline we need to trigger it using a
version control system of course i'm
going to be using git that's the modern
industry standard for version control
all that we need to do now is choose a
cloud vendor i'm going to be using azure
i'll tell you more about that in a
second why terraform you know why would
you want to use terraform for something
like this
terraform makes it easy to reliably and
repeatedly configure cloud
infrastructure it's a declarative
language which means you describe you
know what you want rather than how you
want it built so it's much easier to
code than a you know say an imperative
infrastructure as code language
it's incredibly flexible
it's it's functionality is extended
through plug-in providers and that means
it's multi-vendor it works with any
cloud so you can use terraform with i'm
going to be showing today how we use it
with azure
you can use it with aws you can use it
with google cloud and some of the
smaller vendors as well the seal the
deal terraform also supports the ability
to configure you know the internals of
your kubernetes cluster so you can roll
out containers you can deploy
microservices
to your cluster using terraform
terraform is really smart so as i said
it's declarative so
it it figures out how to create what
you're asking for the sequence of steps
to go through to create that and it gets
even smarter because once you've got
existing infrastructure and you want to
make changes to it you don't have to do
any kind of like step-by-step migration
of your infrastructure you just change
your code so it is the way you want it
to be next you run terraform terraform
figures out you know what what is the
difference what is the delta between
what it was and what you want it to be
and it applies those changes to top it
all off terraform is open source um so
if you wanted to you could actually you
know get into that code base and
contribute to it as i mentioned
terraform works with any cloud vendor
but to demonstrate i need to pick a side
i i like azure i've got a fair bit of
experience with it so that's why i'm
going with azure um it's one of the big
three of course so you know it's one of
the ones that you would pick but i find
azure is pretty beginner friendly
it's pretty easy to use i think that's
how microsoft are really competing
against aws is in usability and when you
sign up for the first time you get 200
starting credit so you've got a bit of
time to experiment
before you start spending cash
now make sure you're going to make sure
you clean up all your cloud resources
after you've done your experimentation
of course because you don't want to burn
your credit and after that you don't
want to burn your cash i'm going to be
showing today how to deploy a kubernetes
cluster on as you are using terraform
you